hey guys I'm Justin we're playing path
of Exile the file of aureus and I'm
joined by a member of the development
team hi I'm Jonathan Rogers I'm the
technical director of granular games and
um yeah I'm keen to answer any questions
are full of Aria so what what are what
is it set up for the fall so basically
your character has been exiled this is
at the start of the game and we're
finally getting opportunity to come back
to arias and find out what happens that
you've been gone so your character we're
going to arrive they find that there's a
middle of a slave uprising the corrupt
leaders of arias who exiled you you know
finally having to face up to some of the
stuff that I've been doing so yeah
you're going to take the side of the
slaves and fight against a bunch of the
a bunch of the guards who are the two of
the Templar order who are around and
arias there's this is this purely a new
place to play this introduce any new
abilities or I'm absolutely so there's
tons of new stuff I mean this is a full
sized expansion so we are you know
there's lots of new items lots of new
areas and the biggest content is is x5
so you know we're continuing the
storyline where we left off at the end
of x4 and I'm adding a huge huge amount
of new areas to play and lots of buses
as well you know we're getting very
proud of the work we've been doing on
bosses recently so what is this specific
area okay so those are the slave pins
it's one of the areas that the you know
the slaves are kept obviously and you
know there's a lot of a lot of stuff
going on here that's right slaves for
free there's you know a lot of guards
that sort of you know have rushed in
here to try and quell the uprising yeah
the other thing another big part of this
expansion is we're also removing cruel
and merciless difficulty and replacing
them with another five acts storyline
that kind of goes through some of the
same areas that you've explored before
but with lots of differences to the
quests and bosses that are there as well
well okay so basically the so in the
past right you'd play you play the game
x1 before and then you play through the
game one before again but with higher
monster levels and so on kind of like a
New Game+ style thing then you play to
begin one more times with his three
playthroughs and what we decided to do
now is rather than do that we're kind of
almost like made a sequel with
in the game which is called part two and
the way it works is you get back to the
same to the area that you went to before
when you get there you know all of the
things that you did in the past have
affected what happened afterwards and so
what you'll find is like oh you know
NPCs are gone and you know you just find
out what happened to them there are new
bosses to fight against new quests to do
and a lot of the areas have just
completely changed so you know for
example areas that you previously
cleansed of corruption you come back and
other all versions in green because you
know you do fix a problem there but then
instead it's been taken over by some
some other people so they're actually
you might say to actually six new acts
in this expansion where we had four
before so kind of increase the amount of
czar the game links by 250% which is
kind of crazy yes a path of exile has
been around for a long time now it's not
a it's not a spring chicken
it isn't so we released the game in 2013
and since then we've been upgrading it's
a huge amount the thing that people
maybe don't realize is that the game is
actually been growing that entire time
in 2016 we had 44 percent more player
hours than we had in 2015 so you know
we're continuing to grow continuing to
expand and the game has come a long way
both in terms of Technology and in terms
of gameplay since that time so you may
notice this area here looks a lot nicer
than the beginning of the game that you
would've played in 2013 and you know
said that you know been keeping off a
lot with lots of engine improvements and
so on and we also have to do a huge
amount of work to get the game to run
well on an Xbox right so you know just
something that yes we're extremely proud
of you know go to games going we're
playing the game on Xbox one right now
mm-hmm
so what kind of trade-offs did you you
have to make to get this working really
like this is a one-for-one the I'm not
going to say it's one for one and there
are differently differences the the
thing that's really interesting about it
is what would have to do for controls we
kind of have to go through every single
skill and work out what makes the most
sense for targeting on an Xbox so
hopefully you're enjoying the you know
the way the controls feel and everything
you know it'll look quite hard on it
it's um one of those things there's like
every skill you're like okay and you
sort of tune this heuristics about like
you know when sure that you're where
should it attack exactly because on PC
you've got the ability to obviously
pinpoint exactly where you want to do an
attack on console you basically have a
direction so
you know that you have to you know if it
were quite hard to do that but we've
been doing that well there are some
skills we'll probably remove for console
because they don't just let it's not
going to work but other skills that
actually feel better you know things
like cyclone just feel better in it when
it's channels and you get to move around
then it doesn't PC just you the way that
that controllers so you know whether
we're very happy with how to end up when
you have new extensions like this you've
seen you find that it increases the
player base you have a lot of either new
players or you have a lot of returning
players who might have fallen off that
come back with it's both of those and
honestly when we're designing a very
expansion we have to consider you know
the the essentially three classes of
players right we have the players who
are new we have the players who are
returning and then we've got the players
were currently playing so we need to
sort of think about like what is the
content for each of those three groups
and then make sure there's something in
the expansion for all of those different
people so yeah that was a constant
challenge but we've been kind of trying
to make sure that we're very like we're
not afraid to try new things we're not
afraid to make changes even though the
player base can sometimes you know be a
bit angry about it right but the best
time to nurse something is when you know
you've got a whole bunch and your
content coming as well they can still
try it out so you know you try to try to
do that this to it we can with that
stuff so where we are now okay so this
is the re square it's kind of the
central location of the of the city and
uh from here there's a bunch of areas
going up going off to the sides and also
you know a bunch of all guards and so on
that you'll need to fight so one of the
things I know players will be excited
about is they've been continuously
saying we did most of these snow areas
no snow in the game so you know finally
delivering on that with a couple of
different areas in exercise so how does
the game do you feel the game has
changed over the years in response to
what fans want and how fans have kind of
helped let you know what they want I
would just say that in terms of like
player customization we've increased
added so many systems the other thing as
well as the in-game has improved
substantially the last expansion
especially the in-game just took a
massive a massive improvement
the average playtime that players play
per day now is up to five hours so you
know like once you start playing the
in-game people just stick around forever
it's quite amazing to see so you know
there's a lot of there's a lot of fun to
be had there and since this is a paid
expansion ring it is not so the game is
the game is free-to-play and every
expansion is also free we make money
with cosmetic microtransactions so
there's actually nothing pay to win in
the game
and the entire game including all
expansions all the content that's been
made for many years as this company's
coming to Xbox as well and we're hoping
to as much as possible to ship all the
expansions exactly the same time on both
PC and Xbox so yeah there's High Templar
of various he's the one who's taken over
the Templar order in Denarius he has a
lot of very talented tax and the other
thing about him is that he despite
evolved quite a lot as you continue so
the beginning it is quite the fight is
quite simple but as you deal damage it's
going to get more and more complicated
or you need some mana so happy yes
yeah so he can raise these statues
they're completely invulnerable so it's
going to stay away from them but after
they coming back in the statues again
they form cover which you can use later
in the fight to block projectiles I'm
selecting become quite useful yeah
definitely use fire okay so you're going
to have to yeah yeah now you've actually
run out of Health flasks now so you've
got to be very careful at some points in
the fight there's going to be a minion
phase and as you kill the minions you're
going to refill your flasks so that's
going to let you regenerate so try and
get another 50% health as fast as you
can and dive in is going to be a minion
phase
you
unfortunately get pretty intense and
down to City of PS during some of us
some of the stuff but that will be
resolved by the time the game go easy so
the target is to try to get the game
running at 60 FPS 60 FPS 1080p X that by
the time we're finished we might need to
do some dynamic resolution scaling but
we should be able to get you should be
able to do pretty well but as I said
it's hard to know exactly because you
know we haven't fully optimized yet
oh yes run away run away yeah yeah yeah
so when he uses that skill you want to
be far far away did you run into any any
issues with getting a free to play game
working working on console because I
know like when you're dealing with
something like Xbox Live or even PSN
that the free-to-play model can seem
problematic I guess in some yeah so I
mean obviously consoles free-to-play as
newer than it is on PC it's something
that we have to have a lot we have a lot
of talks about with Microsoft and so on
about like what you know what can we
sell what can we not sell they some of
the things we do in our business model
on PC they're not necessarily willing
for us to do so you know that that's
something we have to work with them on
but um you know overall and they're
receptive like they want to see like you
know they what they want to make
free-to-play work as well as it does on
PCs doesn't consoles and let's have some
really excellent free-to-play successes
with some of their other games you know
like World of Tanks and so on so they're
definitely interested in increasing
their you know the number for you to
play titles on this store and yeah we're
hoping that we're going to be one of the
big ones
yes what kind of element can you or are
you not able to do on the monetization
side Oh
so I mean like one example is a lot of
our a lot of our packs that we do sell
on PC we include physical merchandise in
order as well and your like t-shirts and
stuff like that and we found that by we
have a we have an almost Kickstarter
like reward tier system on PC so for
example we'll sell a pack that contains
you know like some points but also some
you know like a t-shirt and simply that
and then you go up to the next pack up
that's what my expenses and then it
contains your everything from the pack
below plus like you know sign complete
diet and that kind of stuff you know and
unfortunately Microsoft aren't really
willing to do that kind of stuff like
selling physical goods on a virtual
marketplace so the others just release
details like that that you know we have
to work around so you know and have to
change change a few of those things so
you know it's not a huge deal run away
run away
why don't we well okay okay so you've
just um killed the first form and now
he's turned into the god innocence now
it gets hard it's gonna get hot dog yeah
so yeah so one of the things that's
strictly nasty about this form is that
as he charges around he's going to
unleash I'm a bunch more that sort of
bullet hell style spam but I think if
you get him down a little bit first
before he starts really amping it up
yeah okay there we go
so in this expansion there are 24 major
bosses like this one this is a
particularly important ones that's the
midex phosphate of exercise but yeah as
I talked about before there are there's
a whole part to another's expansion
which I can also show you and there's a
lot of boss fights to be had in there as
well so let's talk about part two but
just to sort of make you understand what
parts was like I'm going to show you a
few areas in part one and then show you
how to changed in part two and that will
mean that we can sort of compare so an
example of that and there's something
just you know like this is but this is
like a sort of as simple as the changes
are but just to give you a basic idea
we're going to go to the first the very
first area of path of exile which is the
trier strand this is where you wake up
on the beach after you been you know the
very beginning of the game so this is
the first day so this is the first area
of the game normally don't worry about
totally get pcs or anything I'm just
sort of showing it to you and there's
what it looks like there's some monsters
which apparently out wanting to actually
show up yeah there you go so there's
monsters on your way over level because
of the first area whereas in the part 2
version of this area things have changed
somewhat so basically all of the noble
people from our outside goes down here
at you spawn a good place and all the
mobile mobile people from Arrius have
kept lead the city I've washed up on
this on the beach and done so now the
the zombies here or basically the
corpses of the noble noblemen Jews who
fled from area right and then that you
know the bosses different at the end of
the area and that kind of stuff show
another example this is an area that has
a monster called cadaverous who's kind
of corrupting the area and you know so
it's all kind of like smoking and
refugees yeah yeah yeah
so in part one you kill that guy so then
when you come back in part two now it
looks like it sounds Divya now looks
like this so obviously it's all verdant
and green everything is returned and
what you'll find is like if you go to
town you know a lot of the NPC's have
either moved on or gone there are new
npcs there who've got new quests and so
on yes they remember your actions from
the past and yeah you're about a little
for this but yeah
oh sorry when you use brother yeah and
you assume and you went to to town
accidentally when you and the town on
those characters unfortunately the first
area that you went to it will do this so
basically you know there's there's a lot
of differences and what we kind of
wanted was like okay like in the past
you just played through exactly the same
game now what you're playing through is
like something that's like feels fresh
and new so it is like recycling probably
like from about 50% recycled stuff from
the past and 50% sort of new things and
there's lots of new monsters and new new
bosses especially here's an example
here's an example of another boss and
another boss fights with the expansion
and once again you're under level so
you're going to get owned but this is a
totem buff and he's the god took a
hammer he yes all the skills are related
to totems and basically they can you
know attack you in a penalty in terms
Oh
so there's an example of took a hammer
so here's another example part two so in
perhaps in part one you explore this
area called the prison in part two you
do enter the prison but rather than
going at the other side of it like you
do in part one and you'll see it climb
up the tower and eventually end up on
the roof so this is where you come from
so you want to go up there and then you
fight so you're on the roof of the
prison now and then you have a fight
with Brutus who was a bocce fighters
Brandfort before and chevron has
reassemble him and powering them up so
here's the skills we had before but only
this sort of powered up versions of them
you have to fight once again you'll get
completely rich by by this box and here
to the level
but just to move the fight forward so
then they swap places and then she comes
out and she's even slightly harder than
Britain's got by forfeit so to be run
around when she's doing that because
she's floating up in the air and then
firing down yes so anyway those are so
examples of sort of stuff you find a
partition base it's like you know it is
similar as what was before but it's also
new as well so that's it that's an
overview of this upcoming expansion for
for path of Exile when when is this new
out so we're looking at sometime in the
middle of the year we're sort of
thinking June we don't have an exact
date yet
but there will be a beta and that will
be earlier that should be either late
April early May and if you want to get
into that then you know sign up on path
of Exile and path of Exile is free and
this expansion is of course going to be
free stuff yeah
you
[Music]